[music playing]
[thumping]
NARRATOR: Spring,
when a young man's
fancy lightly turns to thought.
What's the matter?
Exam week getting you down?
What you need is to
put down that notebook
and take in some of
the beauties of nature.
See what I mean?
[thumping]
[music playing]
But wait a minute,
young lady, how
did you get into this picture?
You see, we're trying to prove
a point about nature and beauty.
And you are not exactly
helping, you know.
Look at your hair.
Look at that blouse,
and the way that skirt
hangs, and those socks.
Sorry, there must
have been a mistake.
You don't seem to be exactly
the type to make this guy
behave like a human being.
[music playing]
But wait a minute.
Come back.
[music playing]
Let's start all over again.
Oh, brother.
NARRATOR: Oh, brother, is right.
Look at that hair,
that skin, that mouth.
And now look at that blouse.
And now look at the
skirt and the socks.
Thanks a lot for helping
us prove a point.
And you, you too know the
value of a good appearance.
[music playing]
[thumping]